The horror genre is home to a lot of quality
flicks, as well as low-budget schlock, making
it hard for a viewer to determine what's good
and what's a waste of time.
Fortunately, we've patched together a list
of those films that are worth the watch.
Though these movies are all pretty different
in subject matter and tone, they're all worthwhile
horror films that have helped define the genre.
The Exorcist
Even four decades after its release, 1973's
The Exorcist is still the possession thriller
by which all others are judged, and for good
reason.
Its ability to infuse a stewing sense of dread
alongside moments of body horror stands alone.
The grotesque tour de force made no apologies
for its use of profanity or gross body fluid
spewing, and it's a lasting classic as a result.
The Texas Chainsaw Massacre
Existing at the perfect intersection of art
and schlock, The Texas Chainsaw Massacre from
1974 is a tangibly dirty, grungy, and frightening
movie.
Launching sequels and a remake franchise that
are by turns too loud and too trashy, the
movie that started it all is an exercise in
unpleasantness.
Its characters are largely unlikable, its
villains the perfect version of incomprehensible
hillbilly cruelty.
"Look what your brother did to the door!"
The plot, essentially about a Texas road trip
that goes south fast, will remind you why
they tell you not to ever talk to strangers,
pick up hitchhikers, or ask questions about
what's going on in the rickety old house at
the edge of town.
Invasion of the Body Snatchers
The very definition of a time-worn tale in
cinema, the 1978 version of Invasion of the
Body Snatchers is a story that's been remade
over and over again, which speaks to the strength
of its premise.
The feeling of being helpless in an unrecognizable
society is something many might identify with,
but the slow burn introduction of these alien
invaders is deeply disturbing.
Thrilling to the final frame, it's a story
that stays with you, anchored by an excellent
cast of smart, unique characters that you
root for — making it hurt all the more when
they fail and fall.
Alien
Ridley Scott's Alien from 1979 continues to
resonate so many years later because it has
a lot of unique qualities — a female protagonist
who's just as strong and capable as anybody
else, a profound sense of isolation, and an
enemy that cannot be reasoned with.
Its characters are constantly under the gun,
tasked with identifying their threat while
simultaneously struggling to survive against
it.
Beyond the impressive intellectual framework,
there are also some shock and awe scenes that
have since become iconic moments of cinema.
The Shining
With brilliant performances from its cast,
quotable lines, unmatched cinematography,
and those awful twins, The Shining from 1980
is an absolute masterpiece.
"Hereee's Johnny!"
It worms its way into your head with beautiful
imagery and a hypnotic pace, showing the dissolution
of one man's sanity over the course of an
isolated winter at the Overlook Hotel.
Stanley Kubrick's at his best here, with deliberate
choices made for each frame that's as visually
stunning as it is packed with unforgettable
tension.
The Thing
John Carpenter is considered the Master of
Horror, and this may well be his best effort
in the genre.
Taking creature feature elements and combining
them with the who's-who paranoia of a Body
Snatchers remake, The Thing from 1982 plants
its characters in isolated Antarctica and
tasks them with surviving against an alien
lifeform that can assume their likenesses.
It's a rich premise that combines subtle,
character-based interplay with full-blown
body horror, like a human head scuttling around
with spider legs.
With a cast to root for and a villain to fear,
The Thing is Exhibit A in the argument for
John Carpenter's primacy among horror engineers,
a remake that runs laps around its source
material and bests any modern attempts to
do better.
Return of the Living Dead
An offshoot of George Romero's Living Dead
films, this spiritual cousin is easily one
of the most goofily enjoyable zombie movies
ever.
1985's Return of the Living Dead follows a
group of dirtbag ravers whose graveyard party
gets upset by a zombie uprising caused by
acid rain.
Return takes a lively approach to its material
that still feels fresh, even if the hilariously
dated fashion of the characters decidedly
does not.
"Why do you eat people?"
"Not people, brains!"
Being too self-serious about zombie material
is a trap that lots of movies fellows fall
into, but Return sidesteps that problem with
aplomb.
It's not a parody — just a great ride.
Jacob's Ladder
This quiet character study from 1990 follows
Jacob Singer, a Vietnam veteran and postal
service worker who slowly comes to believe
that either his sanity or reality itself is
falling apart.
The film is notable for some standout sequences.
Take, for example, Singer's long gurney ride
through a hellish hospital littered with body
parts, blood, and inhuman monsters gone mad.
The sequence has influenced horror media for
decades afterward, so even if you haven't
seen this movie, you've definitely seen its
impact.
In the decades since its release, it's developed
into a noted cult classic, lauded for its
indelible imagery as much as the deep melancholy
at its core.
Scream
The first film ever to kick off the self-aware
horror trend is also still the best.
"Oh just some scary movie."
"You like scary movies?"
"Uh huh."
"What's your favorite scary movie?"
Wes Craven — who was already horror royalty
thanks to The Hills Have Eyes, The People
Under the Stairs, and the Nightmare on Elm
Street franchise — outdid himself with Scream
in 1996.
This funny, freaky slasher flick subverted
every trope in the book and roundly mocked
the horror genre at large, while still scaring
the hell out of its audience.
"Oh you wanna play psycho killer?"
"Can I be the helpless victim?"
The Blair Witch Project
The found-footage project that started it
all, 1999's The Blair Witch Project launched
plenty of copycat projects that never got
anywhere close to the haunted, pine-scented
quality of the original.
The forest itself becomes the monster in this
ultra low-budget camcorder picture, where
every tangle of twigs and leaves takes on
eerie suspicion.
Following a group of hapless young filmmakers
as they circle the wilderness, lost and increasingly
certain they're being hunted, the film is
a story about madness, isolation and distrust
while still infusing a classic ghost story
in its bones.
Its title antagonist is never truly seen and
maybe not even real, but that's part of the
beauty of the film.
The witch's absence offers an uncertainty
that gets to the heart of what horror is — fear,
and a sense of helplessness, in the face of
the unknown.
Audition
Back in the days before OKCupid or eHarmony,
a widowed middle-aged businessman had to get
creative when it came to finding a date…
or at least, that's the premise of Audition
from 1999.
This Japanese horror film is a very slow burn
with a scream-worthy finale, as the poor lovelorn
protagonist realizes that the young lady he's
auditioned to be his new bride comes with
a checkered past and some disturbing baggage.
In addition to boasting stellar performances
and a creative, scary script, Audition has
the added benefit of making your worst Tinder
date look like a great time by comparison.
The Descent
Claustrophobes be wary.
If you've got a fear of being trapped in tight
spaces, The Descent from 2005 is one of the
scariest movies you could watch.
The unique story of a group of female cavers
who get lost in the uncharted depths, The
Descent is a top-notch horror experience that
gets taken to the next level when the heroes
stop spelunking and have to start caving-in
monsters' skulls.
They've got to fight for survival, all while
wading through massive lakes of blood.
Be sure to catch the version with the original
ending, which was deemed too dark for U.S.
audiences and cut from the theatrical release.
The Mist
A lot of Stephen King's horror novels have
been made into movies or TV shows, but only
some of them have been successful at translating
the tension and terror of the source material
to the screen.
"I don't think you'd like it Henry."
The Mist was of the few to get it right thanks
to the unsettling plot tweaks sprinkled in
by writer-director Frank Darabont.
The 2007 film tells the story of a New England
town beset by unspeakable, otherworldly horrors
that descend under the cover of an impenetrable,
mysterious mist.
It's a solid monster movie, but its scariest
moments are the ones that reveal the dark
tribalism of human beings who believe they're
witnessing the end of the world, and it pulls
no punches on that front.
King even famously said that Darabont's gut-wrenching
twist ending for the film is the one he wishes
he'd written himself.
Paranormal Activity
Found footage horror got a fresh face with
this 2007 movie, which proved that you don't
need a gothic mansion or dilapidated cabin
in the woods to make a highly effective haunting
flick.
All the action of Paranormal Activity takes
place in the comfy, carpeted setting of a
suburban townhome, as a pair of newlyweds
learn that they're not entirely alone in their
house.
Like its genre predecessor The Blair Witch
Project, Paranormal Activity is all about
the slow burn.
Even the most ordinary occurrences like a
door swinging shut or a hall light illuminating
offscreen are imbued with foreboding, and
the teeny-tiny cast does a convincing job
of making the "found footage" premise feel
real.
Martyrs
Profoundly disturbing to the point of being
unwatchable, 2008's Martyrs was one of the
progenitors of the French "extreme horror"
movement, and earned that distinction in every
single way.
From the opening sequence, which depicts the
chillingly merciless murder of an entire family,
the movie only gets harder to watch.
It's a "curiosity killed the cat" parable
about revenge, mercy, and humanity's search
for meaning, and it's unlike anything you've
ever seen.
It challenges you to keep watching right up
to the cruel and bitter end.
But watch the original, rather than the 2016
remake -- because that one's scary for a whole
different series of reasons.
Let the Right One In
Not to be confused with Let Me In, the regrettable
American remake, Let the Right One In was
a sleepy Swedish surprise.
In the 2008 pic, a bullied young boy named
Oskar makes friends with an unusual new neighbor
who only comes out at night because, well,
she's a vampire.
But Let the Right One In doesn't go the way
of Twilight or True Blood and try to get too
campy about human-vampire relations.
Instead, it's a smart piece of commentary
on the loneliness of the human condition — that
is, when people aren't being drained of blood,
bursting into flames, or getting torn to shreds
by a bunch of cute little kitties.
You're Next
Home invasion thrillers are a staple subgenre
within the horror-film family, and You're
Next is a perfect specimen of this often-mishandled
storyline.
With an opening scene that sets just the right
mood, a stylish execution, and a bad-ass final
girl who you'll be rooting for from the get-go
— there's nothing about this 2011 movie
that isn't utterly on point.
Except, maybe, for the fact that there's no
sequel.
Goodnight Mommy
This Austrian feature from 2014 is a master
class in making the audience feel very, very
bad.
Two twins develop a syndrome that makes them
believe their mother, lost in depression after
being disfigured in an accident, has been
replaced by an impostor.
The story unfolds with trainwreck inevitability,
as their investigation turns from curious
to cruel, playing with the allegiances of
the audience in an excruciating way.
The story is riddled with blank spaces and
patches of silence where a lesser film would
try to tell the audience too much.
The amazing result is that viewers have to
do the legwork on figuring out what's really
going on.
And the film is not so much about jump surprises
as it is about the pure horror of watching
innocent children do terrible, unspeakable
things.
The Witch
Not only is The Witch historically authentic
to an eerie degree, but its careful approach
to introducing scary, supernatural elements
into the real-life religious anxieties of
colonial New Englanders is intensely unsettling.
And the climax of this 2015 film is an emotional
piece of hell.
A lot hinges on the endings of horror movies,
and this one sticks the landing with confidence.
It's an unsparing picture, the very meaning
of dreadful, and a modern classic.
Get Out
A meet-the-parents situation goes terribly
awry in Jordan Peele's directorial debut Get
Out, which hit theaters in 2017 amid a wave
of well-deserved buzz.
The movie follows interracial couple Rose
and Chris, who are visiting for a weekend
at Rose's parents' estate — a classy place
where the polished veneer of white liberal
tolerance turns out to be masking some deep,
dark, terrifying secrets about why there aren't
more black folks in town.
Get Out fully lives up to the hype, delivering
suspense and scares while also tackling complex
and uncomfortable racial issues with incisive
wit.
If it doesn't make you scream, it'll definitely
make you squirm.
"Sink into the floor, sink."
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!